las pandillas crecían en haití los
desplazados aumentaban y la violencia
detenía la ya históricamente estancada
economía haitiana un colapso que se
evidenció el 7 de julio
el presidente joven el mois fue
asesinado por una unidad presuntamente
formada por 26 colombianos y dos
haitianos estadounidenses su mujer la
primera dama martín moix herida en el
ataque señaló como responsable a la
oligarquía a la que se enfrentaba a su
marido paralelamente a la investigación
inició una lucha de poder el primer
ministro interino claude joseph quien
asumió el liderazgo reivindicaba liderar
el país también lo reclamaba joseph
lambert presidente del senado y
finalmente ariel enric un neurocirujano
designado primer ministro en la semana
de la muerte del presidente joseph y
lambert se retiraron tras presiones
diplomáticas y el martes 20 de julio
ariel enrique tomaba posesión con el
respaldo de las naciones unidas y la
organización de estados américanos de
esta forma se desencallará el relevo de
moix pero la crisis política continúa la
oposición reclama que ya debería
haberse celebrado elecciones contando la
primera victoria del presidente moix en
2015 que fue anulada para el difunto
jefe de estado su reelección en 2017 le
daba el poder hasta 2022
moix antes de su magnicidio ya había
convocado elecciones presidenciales y
legislativas para el próximo 26 de
septiembre comicios que el nuevo primer
ministro ariel en red tendrá que
conseguir que se celebren de una vez por
todas